bonjour je m'appelle pauline du et je
suis infirmière à domicile je viens de
trouver une de mes patientes décédée
chez elle fait partie du métier
chimérique l'a jamais quitté et lee est
né il travaille ses parents mais là
aussi ses grands parents des mineurs des
métallos tous c'est une fille simple
courageuse intelligente on peut monde la
connaît les problèmes les mieux non plus
ça gâche rien salut c'est en dessous sur
son vote à grande-synthe
on dirait pas tu pourrais venir dîner un
soir je voudrais parler à lui raconté
qu'ils avaient encore cambrioler chez
robert qui ça j'ai l'impression qu'il
faudrait aller voir du côté de la cité
léo lagrange du signal qui sont enfoncés
que tout bas ça c'est à voir mais quand
on a en revanche ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'ils ne sont plus ou moins longtemps à
ce point
tu vas avoir une chance rnt bien curieux
imaginez qu elle est partie maintenant
c'est un homme - rigole pas on est en
france au 21ème siècle
je lui dire de membres à votre mari on
m'a chargé de trouver un candidat pour
les municipales et j'ai pensé à toi et
ça serait sur une liste du bloc
patriotique
c'est quelqu'un comme toi des gens est
un proche de jean que c'est une fin
juste elle c'est pas la même chose
et puis c'est une femme je veux changer
des choses c'est pas pareil que joe g
kwh avec ses joueurs
c'est maintenant ou jamais bande à la
[ __ ] tout s'est ligué nickelés vous
savez c'est bien sûr que non c'est
plutôt ça l'amusé beaucoup de ces
roquettes et surveiller
je comprends rien à ce qui se passe je
vois plus mes enfants je peux plus
bosser on préfère que vous veniez plus
pourquoi j'aimerais plaît parce que ça
va devenir chaud pour vous
[Applaudissements]
dans l'est presque au pouvoir ça fait 40
ans je me bats pour ça
[Musique]